if you've been following my channel for
a while now you've probably also been
spending your years following
contradictory and super complicated diet
information and you're probably effing
Fed Up you probably have past or present
grievances about your body you maybe
still have some Hang-Ups about specific
Foods
[Music]
I want to hop in super quick to table
today's sponsor cook Unity so before I
had kids I used to find a lot of joy in
lovingly preparing multi-course meals
from scratch and going shopping for
ingredients and baking bread on a random
Tuesday yeah those were the days and now
with two kids under five hard no so when
we're down south in the states we always
stock up on some of the creative
signature meals from cook Unity so cook
Unity has over 50 talented chefs from
some of the best restaurants in the
country working at a regional micro
kitchens instead of massive production
facilities so you feel like you're
getting a restaurant meal at home
basically you let them know what you
like and what you don't like and you get
to pick a flexible meal plan so as few
as four or as many as 16 meals per week
then you can select from hundreds of
meals that align with your preferences
and dietary restrictions including keto
vegan gluten-free low sodium and more
and they use really high quality Chef
driven ingredients the meals are
delivered fresh not frozen and
compostable recyclable or reusable
packaging along with expiration dates
heating instructions and nutrition stats
and then a few days before your delivery
you get a text to make your selections
for the next week it feels like one huge
huge thing off my plate that I just
cannot screw up so my favorites for my
last haul were the chicken thighs with
braised grapes and olives by Chef
Michelle Bernstein and the oricetti with
broccoli rabe and vegan beyond meat
sausages from Chef John de luche oh and
also the Thai quinoa and veggie salad
from Chef Andreas Mendez but the menu
rotates constantly with a wide range of
different cultural flavors and
preparations so it really helps to fill
the gaps with inspiring fun meals for
those nights when I just like can't so
if you want to try cook Unity out
yourself go to cookunity.com Abby or
click the link in the description and
use my code abby50 to get 50 off of your
first order of meals at the start of my
intuitive eating journey I had a lot of
what we call fear Foods AKA basically
foods that you think about Non-Stop and
you fear that you can't control yourself
around when you finally let yourself
have a taste also guys it's really
important to note here that not all
meals or snacks need to be perfectly
balanced hunger crushing combos
sometimes you just want straight up
McDonald's fries and that is a okay this
is not a set of rules it's a framework
and it only works when the intention is
self-care but for some reason I was
particularly obsessed with sugary cereal
so as part of my recovery I started to
make myself eat cereal every day I
started with it basically just like
straight up in a bowl with some milk
just like I would have done when I was a
kid and I tried to collect data on how
having that bowl of Lucky Charms made my
body feel and how it made me feel
usually when I had like a big bowl of it
just straight up was a little sluggish
kind of constipated and most importantly
still hangry as so he therefore was
forced to spend even more time thinking
about food
hmm
still so good now I would never have
been able to hear this qualitative and
quantitative data from my body when my
mind was barking so loudly in a state of
deprivation and denial so this was a
really huge leap forward for me and once
I had effectively knocked cereal off its
pedestal and neutralized its power I was
able to find little ways to harness the
emotional satisfaction piece of eating
cereal but also Master the physical
satiety piece and that's how my Hunger
crushing combo was born if you're an OG
or regular subbie you probably have
heard me use the term my Hunger crushing
combo this is an evidence-based additive
gentle nutrition framework that serves
as an alternative to all of the rigid
rules that have failed you in the past
most diet advice that we're familiar
with is grounded in restriction and
denial so you know cut out sugar or
gluten snacks whatever this keeps us
trapped in what we call scarce mentality
which almost always results in
overeating or full out binge in order
for a healthy diet to be sustained it
needs to be physically satiating and
emotionally satisfying which is
essentially why my Hunger crushing combo
works by adding a source of fiber
protein and healthy fats AKA my Hunger
crushing compounds to the foods that you
love and crave you're ticking both of
those critical boxes you get to have
your cake and feel good eating it too
hmm
these days I eat cereal several times a
week and usually this is how I do it
with Greek yogurt or cottage cheese for
protein some berries for our fiber and
either some nuts or seeds for healthy
fats it tastes good and it feels good
which brings me to your fear Foods so as
usual I surveyed you guys on my
Community page for your fear foods that
you'd like to see me turn into hunger
crushing combos now I've done a whole
series of these videos so you can check
out my description to see if your fear
food has already been done in a previous
video but we are back at it with another
round of really fun balanced meals and
snacks and I'm hungry so let's eat
hmm
all right first up orange juice as you
can see we already opened it up had a
little taste tester this morning and you
know if I'm honest orange juice was
definitely a fear food for me too or
basically any drink that had calories
um I just saw that as the absolute devil
you know just pure poison
[Music]
[Applause]
and as I discussed in my food rules
video right here I still don't actually
drink a lot of juice and that's because
when I allowed myself to drink said
juice I realized that I actually didn't
like it that much I don't like the film
that it creates in my mouth I don't know
what it is so at this age I got very
sensitive teeth so the thought of
drinking any kind of Beverage that's
like highly acidic or sweet just gives
me the heebie-jeebies like I just know
I'm gonna have to be sitting with a
mouth tray of desensitization gel all
night so I try to avoid but what I do
love is me some orange creamsicle
anything so let's make ourselves little
hunger crushing combo based around some
ojang usually protein shakes in my house
are based around like a milk or a
plant-based milk of adding some kind of
like juicy fruity liquid and I see all
the time in juice bars and smoothie bars
so we're gonna work with it so I've got
a little bit of Greek yogurt here I use
like a higher fat Greek yogurt we've got
some protein we've got some healthy fats
in there I've got some sweet potatoes
tons of fiber lots of vitamin A and we
have finished something off in my
freezer thank God does anyone else like
hoard bags of Frozen like little bits of
frozen fruit and vegetables it's not
good so I'm always so excited when I
finally get to finish off a container
all right I got a ripe banana that's
going to add lots of sweetness and a
nice body I've got some more protein
with some vanilla protein powder some
healthy fats with some oh
it's always scary when I finish a
container of hemp hearts because I'm
like do I have a backup I'm just gonna
hope I do so hemp hearts for healthy fat
and sidebar a lot of people ask me what
is a healthy fat to you Abby and this is
a great question like I don't have
qualifiers for healthy carbs or healthy
proteins for me healthy fats is
basically anything that's not a highly
processed trans fat I want to clarify
healthy fats there because I wouldn't
aim to be adding in you know like a deep
fried batter as your source of fats in
that meal of course it's still going to
contribute to satiety but the idea of
this framework is also to help you get
in a variety of whole nutritious Foods
so that you're not only meeting your
Macros but you're also going to be
hitting those micros as well so I hope
that clarifies that for you all right so
so far everything's in here now I'm
going in with our OJ
that looks good and we can always adjust
this after the fact too
get her creamy
yum okay let's recap so we have protein
our protein powder and Greek yogurt
healthy fats and the hemp parts and the
Greek yogurt because I used a higher fat
option which is key it gives it such
great body and a really nice flavor and
consistency and we have some Fiber in
the sweet potato that I added as well
and most importantly guys this tastes
like the creamsicle little popsicles
that you'd get from one of those creepy
ice cream trucks that drive through your
neighborhood
[Applause]
mmm oh my God this is so much better
than that don't come at me but this
easier on my teeth too Elder Millennial
approved okay next up
I'm gonna really offend some French
people today but I feel this I feel this
you know when I was really afraid of
fats and butter croissants or croissants
definitely felt like a scary Indulgence
to me so I totally see why so many of
you list this as when your top fear
foods but then I went to Europe and I
realized that people ate croissants
every single day and nobody felt guilty
about it so let's channel that European
Vibe today and make ourselves a bougie
ass sandwich let's do it so I've got
some sun-dried tomato pesto here going
down that's a great source of fat
because it's gotten nuts in it and it's
delicious hmm
flavor
kind of like
a bougie mufulada
but it's not
um all right we're gonna go in with some
more healthy fats some avocado avocado
nailed it now I've got some provolone
cheese
and some chicken for a protein oh can't
forget some greens folks a little
Greenery it's the hardest part guys I
don't think you appreciate
how hard it is to Perfect The Art of
Sandwich making what are you an idiot
sandwich like this takes Talent right
here and a lot of patience to get every
single Greenery piece to perform okay
somehow I have to combine these without
a casualty trapped
now that is way better than just like a
Starbucks croissant Am I Wrong let's eat
guys I'm pumped about this I'm super
pumped and I think it's gonna be really
good so let's talk about it again so
we've got healthy fats in our pesto and
our avocado protein in our chicken and
our cheese and some Fiber in the avocado
and our Greenery and
mmm
you know the pesto hits she hits hard
hit me baby
oh nuts a lot of you guys said donuts
and again I feel that I feel like donuts
is top three desserts for me it's like
sticky toffee pudding number one a
really good yeast donut and three would
be like a killer New York style
cheesecake oh no maybe I've got some
more inspiration to go on for our next
episode but when I started to eat donuts
more often I realized that I really
don't feel the need to finish even one
whole donut in most occasions sometimes
I've got a killer donut appetite and I
don't judge myself but I saw these cute
little donuts and I was like you know
what that's like a perfect size Donut
for me and there's sprinkles on top and
my kids are gonna be very happy when I
share a few of these with them this
afternoon poppy not you not you
not this child
no child it has chocolate sorry baby
mean mom also just having a donut for
breakfast I know would not keep me
satiated and satisfied so if you're
going to the drive-through and you need
your donut fix let me show you how to
hunger crush and combo it up
all right let's make a little fun
breakfast Bento Box I love a little
snackable meal so we got our donut I've
got some hard-boiled eggs here some
whole grain crackers I've got some
pistachios
we're gonna throw a variety of different
kind of like fruits strawberries
raspberries
and blueberries
and I don't know about you guys but I
would be very excited to show up to work
with my little coffee tumbler and this
Snack Pack Masterpiece let's recap let's
check it out folks we've got protein in
our eggs healthy fats in our pistachios
lots of fiber in our fruits and our
whole grain crackers and we got
sprinkles have it
she's into it
um
almost chocolate filled mmm
it's like a pearl little snack love this
journey for us oh Nutella this was
another big one and it's also one that
for me it's just like such a super uber
sweet food that I just obsessed over
because I knew it had so many calories
but now that I'm allowed to eat it I've
kind of lost interest and I think this
is again probably because I'm just
getting older and my palate's changing
and my teeth are sensitive and I just
can't bring myself to like put a
spoonful of this in my mouth knowing the
pain that it will inflict that's it I
love Nutella flavored desserts like if
it's on a menu I am going for it so let
me show you how I make some super easy
protein energy balls using the flavor
and sweetness of Nutella but packing in
that fiber protein and healthy fats
let's do it we splurged on some Costco
hazelnuts honestly I wouldn't have
bought them if they weren't on sale
because they are effing expensive
we've got rolled oats
one two
three tons of fiber right there I've got
some vanilla protein powder you could
easily use chocolate here as well I just
have vanilla uh let's say let's say some
more hand parts
I found more
it'll be a sad day if I didn't have a
backup pack in the pantry let's get some
peanut butter here going because it's
cheaper than hazelnut butter
looks about right
get that in there oh there's nothing
like a fresh
foil wrapped
container Nutella check that out
smells like Italy to me because I
consumed Nutella flavored everything
when I was in Italy so good all right
couple tablespoons of that
but yeah my teeth ache just like looking
at a spoonful of that all right it's
probably good we want to impart all that
Nutella flavor
um
look at that but of course I don't want
my teeth to like ache for days so I
think that's gonna be good
[Music]
we need some salt
bring up that flavor flavor I think I
need some vanilla tiny splash
all right now we pulse
[Music]
just something to bring this together
a couple tablespoons
but I taste all the nutellas
she good
okay now I'm gonna pulse in some
chocolate chips
so we got big balls small balls squishy
balls abnormally shaped balls we don't
discriminate here in Abby's kitchen it's
not about the size of the ball it's what
you do with it that's what my husband
says anyway
mmm it smells so good guys guys all
right let's recap we got tons
in the Hazel Hazel and the nut butter
plus protein and all the nuts and seeds
as well as the protein powder as well as
a lot of fiber in our oats and we got
Nutella
oh my God this is good full Nutella
experience without the aching teeth
that's my jam
it's so good no woman
No Cry
foreign
s actually these are Smarties because I
buy the ones without the artificial food
dyes and I don't know if M Ms do that
yet but same diff same diff same deal
same same same but different whatever I
got a lot of Quests for M m's on my
Community page and I just happen to have
a ton of them left from my son's
birthday parties so this seemed like an
opportune time to turn them into a
hunger crushing combo and one of my
favorite ways to eat M M's is in
pancakes like when you go to one of
those like diners they always have m m
Pancakes on the menu it's just so
nostalgic it's so fun my kids are
obsessed so I thought why not make m m
pancakes but with a little protein
upgrade let's do it so these days
there's like a million different protein
pancake mixes on the market I'm just
using the one that's easy and accessible
for me but I've got a little simple way
to upgrade it just to boost the
nutrition even more so we got our
protein pancake mix down I'm gonna add a
generous
handful
of wheat bran basically I add this to
any of my baked goods especially if I'm
going to give them to the kids because
it's a great source of fiber and it's
very inexpensive to buy a whole big bag
like this also since I've got the hemp
hearts out for basically every other
recipe gonna throw some of those down
too some healthy fats and for some
natural sweetness I've got a ripe banana
all right
then we're just going to kind of eyeball
this I'm using a pea protein milk
because again just gonna bump up the
protein even more and we mix her up
get them chunks out all right I like
little baby mini pancakes also because I
struggle with flipping them so it's
lower risk let's get one of these down
they don't need to be perfect circles
guys don't judge me for
then we're going to throw down some of
the colorful ones even though I know
that the natural food dyes typically
they don't survive the heat so well
and FYI I'm not fear-mongering food dyes
if you can tolerate them you do you me
and my son are just a little bit
sensitive so I typically try to avoid
them when I have the option I'm heavily
curating each pancake and I'm the only
one in the house who's gonna give
you need a green it's a weird looking
green it's like a pukey green that one's
a nice green oh yeah yeah the
anticipation
you think if I watch it it'll cook
faster
very nervous I always feel so much
pressure while making pancakes in front
of an audience it always works out
better when I'm alone it's like they
know
ready
whoa
perfect awkward flip angle
nice all right down nice
[Music]
come this far guys I can't it up
now I got the beat going still that's a
good sign
okay the kid in me is very excited right
now but I also feel like we can upgrade
it just a hint to make it a even more
balanced nutritious meal so I typically
like to put Little Greek yogurt
on top of my pancakes or waffles I've
got some berries here throw these guys
down
well if they want to hang out and I've
got some almonds for a little crunch
Factor
and personally I think that these are
probably sweet enough that I don't need
a whole lot of maple syrup on top but
since she's here it does make for a
delicious looking hero shot I'm so
excited okay let's recap guys we have
protein in our protein pancake mix plus
the Greek yogurt on top healthy fats in
some of the hemp hearts I added plus the
almonds on top as well and fiber in the
pancake mix plus the added wheat brand
that is key it's such an easy addition
you can add to any of your baked Staples
and I also added some berries as well
this is so good oh gotta get everything
in
the m m just like melting in my mouth
I'm here for that yup nothing to be
scared of here folks
so many delicious recipes so much great
inspiration and let this be another
reminder that you do not need to make
every meal or snack an HCC my Hunger
crushing combo is not a rule it's a
framework that's designed to help you
uniquely feel your best and sometimes a
handful of M M's Just Hits different and
that is A-Okay so if you guys like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on some of your
fear foods that you want us to be turned
into hunger cushion combos hit up the
link below if you want to get my
exclusive handbook on Hunger crushing
Combos and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]